acb devastates ill-prepared democrats
nancy pelosi loses it on cnn's wolf
blitzer for asking her
a basic question and nicole hannah jones
has a rather revealing meltdown i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben well yesterday was another good day
for amy coney barrett it turns out that
she's very good at her job she's also
very good at defending herself and
defending her judicial philosophy
democrats however
are not particularly good at their job
which was to somehow paint amy coney
barrett
as a deplorable paint her as a crazy
right winger who was basically using the
constitution as a guise for her own
political viewpoint they did not succeed
in this
and so as for our usual arrangement
they've decided to change the terms of
the debate
itself we are now living in a world
where terms randomly
shift definition in chameleonic fashion
it's really impressive
court packing over the last week turn
from a very clear and concise term
referring to adding seats to a court in
order to change the political
constituency of that court
into filling seats that are open okay
that
that just happened and democrats went
they started it and then the media went
along with it and suddenly it became
rote to suggest that it is court packing
if you fill open seats or if you hold
open seats because
you do not wish to confirm somebody of
the opposite political party that is not
in fact court packing well now as we are
about to see
the democrats are starting to trot out a
new narrative
and that new narrative is that the term
sexual preference
is homophobic sexual preference itself
that term
is homophobic they're trying this one
when you are losing the argument you
should simply change the rules of the
game
this is why honestly yeah we say this is
how you got trump too often but it is
true this is how you got trump people
get so angry
at the calvin ball the democrats in the
media are constantly playing that
they're like we're sick of the bs
just bring the guy who's gonna break
everything just just the guy who's gonna
just bring that guy because there is
nothing quite as
irritating as watching people change the
rules of the game in real time and then
declaring
that they are the defenders of fairness
decency and light
so i'll explain how all of that happened
as this
show develops but let's begin with amy
coney barrett herself
so coney barrett is an excellent
judicial candidate
she has a very clear and concise
judicial philosophy she understands
originalism really well and she
expresses it
really well here was judge amy coney
baird of the second circuit court of
appeals yesterday
explaining the role of a judge in a
democracy
part of the rationale for courts
adhering to the rule of law
and for judges taking great care to
avoid imposing their policy preferences
is that it's inconsistent with democracy
nobody wants to live in accord with the
law of amy i'm sure
my children don't even want to do that
so i can't as a judge
get up on the bench and say you're going
to live by my policy preferences because
i have life tenure and you can't kick me
out if you don't like them
so she understands the rule of a judge
what a judge is supposed to do
unlike democrats and democrat appointees
who believe that a judge's job
is simply to define the universe for
everybody else
amy coney barrett continued along these
lines because it's not up to me to
update the constitution we have an
amendment process if you wish to update
the constitution that is up to congress
it is up to the states
they can do all of this here is amy
coney barrett saying she is not in fact
the ruler of the universe
you said you're an originalist is that
true
what does that mean in english okay so
in english
that means that i interpret the
constitution
as a law that i interpret its text as
text and i understand it to have the
meaning that it had
at the time people ratified it so that
meaning doesn't change
over time and it's not up to me to
update it or
infuse my own policy views into it okay
this kind of stuff takes democrats off
to no end because of course
they want justices to impose their own
policy views on the constitution so long
as they are from the left
and in order to justify that they have
to openly state or imply
that originalists are actually just
liars they don't actually care about the
original meaning of the constitution
they're just using that
as a guise in order to forward their own
political agenda
sort of like how the 1619 project
suggests the declaration of independence
was a bunch of lies written and designed
in order to protect slavery which of
course is untrue
people on the left pretend that
originalism is about somehow
shoehorning in your right-wing policy
preferences into the law
via this document the constitution well
that's a lot of projection because it is
the democrats it is democrats appointees
who have historically shoehorned their
own policy preferences
into law in fact you can see this
statistically ilya shapiro
of cato institute pointed out that
during the 2019 supreme court term
there were 67 decisions the four
justices appointed by democrats voted
together 51
times out of the 67. republican
appointees only voted together
37 times in other words there's a lot of
difference between how republican
appointed justice's vote
people are heterodox and how they
approach these issues if they are
originalists or textualists
on a fundamental level republican
appointees don't see their job
as policy preference they see their job
as interpreting the law faithfully
but democrats only celebrate the court
when the court is doing their policy
preference this is why they love roe
versus wade so much roe vs weight is a
terrible case
legally even its own advocates will
admit it has nothing to do with the
constitution it's why some of the most
celebrated positions
in constitutional law our positions left
loves
specifically because they have nothing
to do with the constitution and some of
their favorite quotes are things like
this from planned parenthood versus
casey
where they say that every person in the
united states quote has the right to
quote define one's own concept of
existence
of meaning of the universe and of the
mystery of human life
well if they really believed that then
presumably you'd be able to decide that
on the level of the locality or a state
but what they really mean is that the
supreme court is
going to define for everybody their
their specific
definition of the concept of existence
meaning the universe and the mystery of
human life what the hell does that have
to do
with the constitution democrats see
nothing but wonder in supreme court
justices
declaring that the judiciary has been
delegated enforcement of a quote charter
protecting the right of all persons to
enjoy liberty
as we learn its meeting in other words
the supreme court gets to be the
evolving standards of decency by which
we are all judged
another supreme court quote evolving
standards of decency they don't say that
when we have evolving standards of
decency we get to vote on those evolving
standards of decency that's just called
the democratic republic
they say that they get to cram down on
all of us their own evolving standard
of decency they believe that they get to
make law via emanations and penumbras
from the constitution that's griswold
versus connecticut of 1965
it was on that slim read that roe versus
wade is based this is what democrats
want from the court
but this is not what originalists do and
this is why democrats are so angry at
originalists like acb
because number one they don't like
originalism originalism defeats their
definition of the court
and two originalism gives the lie to
their cynical viewpoint which is that
judges ought to
basically impose their own vision of the
law on the rest of the country
so acb continued along these lines she
explicitly rebuked
essentially the barack obama vision of a
judge so barack obama infamously stated
that he wanted judges with empathy and
life experiences because their life
experiences would help them to find how
they made judgments
acb said i have interesting life
experiences they have nothing whatsoever
to do
with how i judge a case while my life
experiences
i think you know i hope have given me
wisdom and compassion they don't dictate
how i decide cases
um because you know as we discussed
before and i've discussed a couple of
times
sometimes you have to decide cases in
ways where you don't like the result
so while i hope that my family has made
me a better person
and my children definitely have given me
new perspectives
on life i still and applying the law and
deciding cases
you know don't let those experiences
dictate the outcome okay so
normally the way that the democrats
fight this sort of thing is by claiming
that the person doesn't have empathy
that the the judicial nominee is cruel
and vicious
for not using their own life experiences
not looking into their hearts before
interpreting constitutional law there's
only one problem
amy coney barrett is a particularly
sympathetic figure
she is not only a very brilliant legal
mind she also happens to be
a mom of seven and uh she's very
personable and this came across
very well in the hearings yesterday here
was amy coney barrett talking about
her adoption of two children from haiti
when jessie and i were engaged we met
another couple
who had adopted in this instance it was
a couple who had adopted a child with
special needs
and then we also met another couple who
had adopted a few children
internationally
and we decided at that point while we
were engaged that at some point in the
future
we wanted to do that ourselves and i
guess we had imagined initially that we
would
have whatever biological kids that we
had decided to have and then
adopt at the end but after we had our
first daughter
emma we thought well why wait
okay well that does not seem like an
unsympathetic terrible person to me
which is what democrats would prefer to
paint her as they'd also prefer to paint
her as a racist
it makes it kind of difficult when she's
obviously not a racist so here was acb
yesterday
talking about the george floyd video and
watching it with her two black children
i was there and my 17 year old daughter
vivian who's adopted from haiti
all of this was erupting it was very
difficult for her
we wept together in my room and then it
was also difficult
for my daughter julia who's ten i had to
try to explain some of this
to them i mean my children to this point
in their lives have had the benefit of
growing up in a cocoon where they have
not yet experienced
hatred or violence um and for vivian
you know to understand that there would
be a risk to her brother or the son she
might have one day
of that kind of brutality
has been an ongoing conversation it's a
difficult one for us like it is for
americans all over the country okay the
other problem for them is
it turns out that amy coney barrett does
represent a lot of viewpoints from the
middle of the country she lives a
lifestyle that many in the middle of the
country can identify but people on the
coast sometimes have trouble identifying
you know i until very recently lived in
los angeles with my my parents lived
very closely nearby
my mom worked in hollywood and at her
office
sometimes she was asked how many kids
she would she had and she said i have
four kids and people would look at her
cross-eyed four kids that's so many
children of course in the religious
community
that's not a lot of children right we're
orthodox jews and in the orthodox jewish
community if you say you have four kids
say okay what happened to the other
three
right because the fact is that the
orthodox jewish
community like the catholic community uh
is is very fertile
okay well there are certain cultural
things about living in the middle of the
country or living in a religious
community that people find absolutely
natural in the middle of the country but
people on the coast
really don't and you can tell by the
media coverage yesterday amy coney
barrett was asked whether her family
owns a gun and she said yes
and the media were like oh my god she
owns a gun and the 100 million gun
owners in america are like okay so
like good she should own a gun i mean
it's good to be able to defend yourself
here's amy coney barrett yesterday
when it comes to your personal
views about this topic do you own a gun
uh we do own a gun okay uh
all right uh do you think you could
fairly decide a case even though you own
a gun
yes judges can't just wake up one day
and say i have an agenda i like guns i
hate guns i like abortion i hate
abortion and walk in like a
a royal queen and impose you know their
will on the world
okay that of course is exactly right
again she's saying my own personal views
on these issues don't have any relevance
to interpreting the law which of course
is right i mean that is what a judge is
supposed to do it's your job is to judge
right it is not to impose it is to judge
there's a certain irony to the fact that
if amy coney barrett had gone in there
and said i've had three abortions the
democrats would be cheering
but if she says that her family has a
gun the democrats are scared beyond all
measure
they'll say something about the relative
moral viewpoint of the various political
sides
the most viral moment from being coney
berry yesterday happened when she was
asked specifically
by john cornyn of texas to show the
notes that she was using
during the hearing so all of the
democratic senators they brought like
big binders of notes to try and question
amy coney barrett
and coney barrett was asked so what kind
of notes are you using in order to
respond to all of this
uh and uh she had a response
you know most of us have multiple
notebooks and notes and books and things
like that in front of us can you hold up
what you've been referring to and
answering our questions
is there anything on it uh that
letterhead that says united states
senate
that's imp that's impressive well slay
queen but actually like slay queen
that's kind of awesome
right that's kind of awesome the fact is
as we'll see when it came to
her running circles around the democrats
intellectually it was
it was fairly obvious and democrats
tried tried to get their viral moments
but they completely failed and so
they've now been relegated to rewriting
the english language
we'll get to that in uh in just one
second first
we need to talk about the fact that when
you are running a business hr issues
actually matter
hr issues can absolutely kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
and hr managers salaries they are not
cheap they average seventy thousand
dollars a year
bambi it's about b-a-m-b-e was created
specifically for small businesses
because you don't actually want to spend
your time doing hr all you want to do is
create products and services for others
but you're going to need to cover hr or
it could cost you hundreds of thousands
or millions of dollars
you can get a dedicated hr manager from
bambi craft hr policy maintain your
compliance all for just 99 bucks a month
with bambi you can change
hr from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone
email or real-time chat from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business and help
you manage your employees day-to-day all
for just 99 bucks a month month to month
there are no hidden fees
cancel any time you didn't start your
business because you feel like spending
time on hr compliance is super fun
there's a reason that everybody hates
toby on the office and the fact is what
you need is hr
and you need hr done quickly and easily
and inexpensively and bammy can get it
done for you right now go to bambi.com
right now schedule your free hr audit
that is bambi.com shapiro spelled bam to
the bee.com
shapiro go check them out right now okay
so the democrats
spent the entire time trying to do
gotchas against amy
coney barrett that was their big thing
they were going to gotcha amy coney
barrett over and over and over
well there's one problem which is that
back in 1993 democrats established a
rule it was called the ginsburg
rule it was named after ruth bayer
ginsburg because ruth bader ginsburg
was an aclu litigator who had argued in
favor of legalizing prostitution
against separate prisons for men and
women and she had speculated that there
was a constitutional right to polygamy
it was back in 1993
and republicans were preparing to ask
her all of these difficult questions and
so democrats came up with a rule
this rule was actually crafted
handcrafted by one senator
from delaware named joseph biden he came
up with the ginsburg rule
the rule was that you could not actually
ask a question
or allow judges to answer questions on
issues likely to come before the courts
or make any statement that would create
the appearance that they are not
impartial
so senator biden said that between 19
that basically nominees never testified
during confirmation hearings prior to
1955.
in 1949 there was a nominee who was
called to testify and refused and was
still confirmed this all according to
heritage
foundation biden warned senators not to
ask questions about how ginsberg will
decide any specific case that may come
before her
ginsburg followed joe biden's road map
senator pat leahy who was on the who was
still in the senate at that time senator
leahy has been in the senate since the
establishment of vermont as a state in
the 1770s
he asked about the religion clauses of
the first amendment and ginsburg said i
prefer not to address a question like
that
leahy pressed her for interpretation of
supreme court president and ginsburg
said i would prefer to await a
particular case
and then late he said i understand just
trying judge just trying
ginsburg just refused to answer over and
over and over she refused two senators
requests to address
gay rights should anything i say could
be taken as a hint or a forecast on how
i would treat a classification that is
going to be in question
before the court again this was called
the ginsburg rule
ed miese the former u.s attorney general
writes about this
okay here was ruth bader ginsburg in
1993 helping to establish the so-called
ginsburg rule
a judge sworn to decide impartially
can offer no forecasts
no hints for that would show
not only disregard for the specifics of
the particular case
it would display disdain for the entire
judicial process okay so democrats now
are angry at the ginsburg rule again
this is how it works this is all calvin
ball
right from the calvin and hobbes
cartoons in which the rules are
constantly changing it's just calvin
ball
there's a famous baseball movie called
bang the drum
slowly in which baseball players win
money
from suspected from unsuspecting people
in uh in sort of bars and hotels they
understand that kind of commoners want
to play
play cards with them and so they set up
a game
and the game is literally called the fun
and exciting game with no rules
and they just randomly change the rules
because they understand that commoners
want to play
with them this is what democrats do what
democrats do
is they sit around and they establish
rules that they then break as soon as
those rules are no longer convenient to
them
so yesterday every democrat all of whom
most of these democrats were were there
in 1993 all of them know about the
so-called ginsburg rule
okay all of them decided it was very bad
for amy coney barrett not to violate the
ginsburg
rule so here was dianne feinstein trying
to press amy coney barrett about roe
versus wade and amy coney barrett saying
listen
i can't speak to how i will adjudicate
on a case that has yet to come before me
and if i give you my specific opinion on
how roe vs wade
was decided then you may take that as an
indicator of how i'm going to rule on a
case
in which roe vs wade is the president
and i'm not going to do that
now let me be frank about this i think
the ginsburg rule is stupid i think the
ginsburg rule is idiotic i think you
should be able to ask a judicial nominee
about anything under the sun
but unfortunately because democrats have
politicized the court this has become
impossible the ginsburg rule was a
natural reaction to the borking of
robert bork
in the 1980s robert bork was brought up
before the senate
and joe biden was involved in this then
too he was involved in
going after bork and calling him a
racist and suggesting
that he was a benighted refugee from
and then republicans said okay fine well
we're going to ask ruth bader ginsburg
the same question so democrats set up
the ginsburg rule
and now democrats want to violate the
ginsburg rule because again there's a
republican nominee
before them so here was here was dianne
feinstein going
after amy coney barrett do you agree
with justice scalia's view
that roe was wrongly decided
senator i completely understand why you
are asking the question
but again i can't pre-commit
or say yes i'm going in with some agenda
because i'm not
do you agree with justice scalia's view
that roe
can and should be overturned by the
supreme court
well i think my answer is the same
because you know that's a case
that's litigated okay and uh you can see
feinstein is very angry that you want to
answer a question on real versus way the
goal here
is to get acb to say she's going to
overturn roe which by the way
roe is not going to get overturned even
if amy coney barrett were to vote over
turn row i think there are best three
votes on the supreme court
certainly not five to overturn roe
versus wade robertson can vote for it
kavanaugh is not going to vote for it i
don't think gorsuch would vote for it
so i think at best you have three votes
on the supreme court to overturn roe
versus wade
then barrett replied to dianne feinstein
listen you keep wanting me to say
political things i'm not going to say
political things
if you want to do something political
you know you're sitting in a body called
the united states senate you can do it
anytime you choose
any issue that would arise under the
affordable care act or any other statute
should be determined by the law by
looking at the text of the statute by
looking at precedent
the same way that it would for anyone
and
if there were policy differences or
policy consequences those are for this
body um
for the court it's really a question of
adhering to the law
going where the law leads and leaving
the policy decisions up to you
that of course is exactly right okay so
now the democrats start to get more and
more desperate so amy klobuchar
tries to ask acb about roe in a
different way she asks whether it
constitutes quote-unquote super
precedent super precedent is a case
that is so well established in the
american political system
that it would be impossible to overturn
it regardless as to whether there are
legal flaws in the reasoning of the case
so brown versus board is a clear and
obvious example
of what supreme court scholars have
called super president precedent that
will never be
overturned simply because it has been so
deeply embedded in the life of our
nation right marbury versus madison is
super precedent
roe vs wade is clearly not super
precedent because super precedent is
something that is so well established
there is no debate over it any longer
like there is no debate
over segregation in the united states
there's no debate over whether it is
legal there's no debate over whether it
is good
there's no debate over whether the 14th
amendment allows it right it is super
precedent there is debate every single
day
every single day over roe vs wade
because roe vs wade was not only
precipitously decided it was wrongly
decided
so it is certainly not super precedent
okay so
in a second we'll get to amy coney
barrett's answer on that particular
question
first let us talk about the fact that
you're spending off a lot of time on
that sofa lately and if you do not have
an all form so if i honestly don't even
know what you're doing with your life i
mean this is like an incredible
incredible sofa because it's not gonna
cost you a fortune it's incredibly
durable it is super comfortable
so comfortable in fact that when i have
relatives come over people sort of fight
on who
gets to sleep on the all-form sofa
because the sofa is more comfortable
than many of the beds
in our house if you've been listening to
the show for a while you've heard me
talk about my helix sleep mattress well
the same people
make all form sofas all form makes
premium customizable sofas and chairs
shipped directly to your door
what makes an all form sofa really cool
well for starters it's the easiest way
you can customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores
you can pick your fabric it is spill
stain scratch resistant the sofa color
the color of the legs sofa size and
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone
you can always start small and buy more
seats later on if you want your all-form
sofa to grow and change with you
when you move all form sofas they're
also delivered directly to your home
with fast free shipping in the past if
you wanted to order a sofa it could take
weeks
even months to arrive you would need
somebody to come and assemble it in your
home
all form will take you just three or
seven days to arrive in the mail you can
assemble it yourself in just a few
minutes no tools needed i know because i
have done this
if getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky don't worry you get
100 days to decide if you want to keep
it
which is more than three months if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free give you a full refund and they
have a forever warranty so what do you
have to lose
go to all form dot com slash ben right
now they're offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com ben
again that is allform.com as i say our
all form sofa is tremendous
we have the the sectional with uh it's
chase
it's a three-seat sofa with chase in the
sand color with espresso legs it's
fantastic everybody loves it go check it
out right now
com allform.com ben okay so the
democrats go increasingly desperate
during this hearing with acb
so amy klobuchar confuses herself by
asking amy coney barrett
about super precedent and it doesn't go
great for amy klobuchar
is row a super precedent how would you
define super precedent
i i actually i might have thought
someday i'd be sitting in that chair i'm
not i'm up here so i'm asking okay
well people use super precedent
differently okay the way that it's used
in the scholarship and the way that i
was using it and the article that you're
reading from
was to define cases that are so well
settled
that no political actors and no people
seriously push for their overruling and
i'm
answering a lot of questions about roe
which i think indicates that roe doesn't
fall in that category
owned with facts and logic amy coney
barrett for the win
i mean this is why you don't leave
open-ended i mean
klobuchar's a lawyer don't ask questions
you don't know the answers to if you
have a definition of super precedent lay
it out there and then
ask amy coney barrett whether it
fulfills the definition if you allow amy
coney barrett
to set the definition of super precedent
of course she's going to define it in
the way that she has defined it before
amy klobuchar did not look good in that
exchange it got progressively worse for
democrats dick durbin who's an idiot
started berating amy coney barrett over
indiana
gun laws which like i wasn't aware that
she set indiana gun laws or that she's a
legislature
that she's a legislator in the indiana
state assembly or anything
here is senator dick durbin being an
idiot we know how it works
where you live you know how it works
there's a traffic between chicago
northern indiana and michigan going on
constantly
gun shows are held in gary indiana and
other places
and when they're selling these firearms
without background checks
unfortunately these gang bangers and
thugs fill up the trunks of their cars
with firearms and head into the city of
chicago
and kill everyone from infants to older
people it's just
it's a horrific situation okay so what
does that have to do with
amy coney barrett exactly the answer is
uh nothing cory booker mr potato head
the worst actor in the united states
senate he put on his angry eyes to
question amy coney barrett
and then he blinked very seriously and
then
he articulated all of his words because
he is
the worst at mouth man here is here is
senator cory booker from
new jersey questioning amy coney barrett
on whether she supports a white
supremacy
yes i'm sure she i'm sure that she is a
member of the kkk with her two adopted
black children go senator booker
i want to just ask you very simply i
imagine you'll give me a very short
resolute answer
but you condemn white supremacy correct
yes
thank you i'm glad to see that you said
that i wish our president
she literally cannot believe would say
that so resolutely unequivocally as well
and she's like what in the f are you
talking about cory book are you an idiot
and the answer is yes cory booker is in
fact
an idiot so like the looks i mean
i'm old enough to remember that vice
presidential debate where kamala harris
was was doing the
fake laugh and the weird smirk amy coney
barrett's facial expressions are so much
more slay queen than kamala harris's
it's not even close
she's looking at him like are you a dumb
ass and the answer of course is
he is he is in fact a dumbass it got
even worse
than that so we'll save the very very
best for last but
maisie hirono asked a couple of
questions one of them was so beyond the
pale stupid
that it is nearly impossible to describe
how stupid it is it was immediately
picked up by the media and turned into
a bizarre narrative they literally
shifted dictionary definitions to meet
democratic talking points we'll get to
that in a second but
she also asked this was her less dumb
question okay let's get to her left so
maisie hirono the stupidest person in
the in the united states i mean she is a
i mean a pure full-scale iq of a
potato
and i don't even mean like a baked
potato i mean like a raw potato pulled
directly from the ground a full-on tuber
pulled directly from a field
that is the brain power of maisie hirono
the democrat from hawaii
she asked acb randomly if she had ever
committed sexual assault
i'm gonna go no on that one so we've now
been asked whether acb
uh likes white supremacy and also if she
is a rapist
was did you just have this one left over
from the kavanaugh hearings or what
here's maisie hirono i ask each nominee
these two questions and i will ask them
of you since you became a legal adult
have you ever
made unwanted requests for sexual favors
or committed any verbal
or physical harassment or assault over
sexual nature
now senator hirono have you ever faced
discipline or entered into a settlement
related to this kind of conduct no
senator
she's trying to hard not to laugh right
now
because what the hell you literally just
spent time
in a supreme court hearing asking a
catholic mother of seven
whether she has engaged in sexual
harassment or assault
yeah man yeah and then
we got sheldon whitehouse i mean this is
these are the people you elect
folks i have a question do you want to
give any of these people more power
like you can say that the republicans in
the senate are are idiots you can say
that the democrats and the senator
idiots
okay if they're all idiots why do you
want to give them more power i don't
understand i really do not understand
americans keep saying how much they hate
congress and how much they hate the
president and how much they hate the
federal government
and then they're like but what if we
gave them more power okay here is
brilliant
brilliant sherlock holmesian sleuth
sheldon whitehouse from rhode island
yeah this guy is just the this is this
is me
trying to explain you know talmudic
injunctions about how to set up an a
roof to people who don't even know what
a jew is this is like
what is he even doing right here i don't
i don't know
he takes out a chart to explain how this
is all driven by money
money sheldon whitehouse he takes out a
chart
he he first took out a chart i have to
say he took out a big sign and it said
the scheme
as though it was one of those act breaks
in a tarantino film
he broke like a placard said the scheme
and then you sort of expected
you know like tom sizemore to walk out
and start speaking in jargon
to harvey keitel or something he said
the scheme
okay then he uh he takes out a sign
that has on it a bunch of words that
have very little to do with each other
and a bunch of money signs
and he starts explaining this thing like
charlie day and it's always
it's always sunny in philadelphia uh
here here we go sheldon whitehouse and
by the way the point that he's making is
that conservative groups want
conservative justices appointed
that's his point and and he starts like
taking yarn
and using it like carry on homeland to
make one of these giant fbi boards
sheldon whitehouse genius sherlock
holmes and sleuth
in all cases there's big anonymous money
behind various
lanes of activity one lane of activity
is through the conduit of the federalist
society
it's managed by a guy was managed by a
guy named leonard leo
and it's taken over the selection of
judicial nominees
all the same funders over and over again
bringing the cases and providing this
orchestrated
orchestrated chorus of amiki
then the same group also funds the
federalist society over here
it was an 80 to zero five to four
partisan route ransacking
that clip and then there's a cutaway to
lindsey graham and graham's like
what what are they putting this guy's
coffee what in the world is going on
it did not go great for sheldon
whitehouse by the way uh cruz then blow
torched sheldon whitehouse he pointed
out you know who spends an awful lot of
money on
on legal issues everyone including the
left
is sometimes for good sometimes for bad
and the fact is
that the the court system in the united
states has routinely been used in order
to
make certain laws illegal in order to
strike down certain laws
in the the entire rosa parks heroic
story was orchestrated by the naacp i
mean it was not
it was not that rosa parks spontaneously
decided to sit down on the back of the
bus it was well planned
with other local leaders like this sort
of stuff has been done for
years on end right brown versus board
was a legal strategy that was undertaken
by the naacp
like this notion that that political
groups don't spend money
in the in the realm of law is bizarre
here is cruz just going after sheldon
whitehouse and blow torching him
the senator from rhode island talked
about big corporate powers
without acknowledging that the
contributions from the fortune 500 in
this presidential election
overwhelmingly favor joe biden and the
democrats so
all of the great umbrage about
the corporate interests are spending
dark money
is wildly in conflict
with the actual facts that the corporate
interests that are spending dark money
are funding the democrats
okay that of course is exactly true okay
so this brings us to the the
key moment of the entire day it had
nothing to do with amy coney barrett
because coney bear will be confirmed
what it had to do with is again this
absurd
move to redefine basic
terms of language in order to drive
narratives
it's incredible we've watched it happen
again with court packing in the last two
weeks
and now we're watching it happen with
the term sexual preference so sometime
yesterday there's a producer for
lawrence o'donnell who got angry at amy
coney bear because she used the term
sexual preference which is a widely used
term it's been used
by the gay advocacy magazine the
advocate joe biden used it
less than five months ago during a
debate i believe uh
or at least during a rally and
and judge amy coney barrett used it when
she was speaking about sexual preference
meaning like are you straight or
are you gay or are you bisexual there is
nothing discriminatory about the term
sexual preference
nothing okay this this they've tried so
this guy got angry he said sexual
preference suggests
that we have a choice in how we choose
to prefer things
well no actually it doesn't suggest that
at all we have lots of preferences in
our daily life that are biologically
driven
many of them right the the term sexual
preference
has been widely used for decades at this
point
in fact sexual preference was a term
that was widely used in the gay
community for for many years it's used
right now
okay but the but mazie hirono picked
this up and then decided amy coney
barrett was a head
a an obnoxious heteronormative
homophobe because she used the term
sexual preference
which is incredible i mean this is just
absurd so here's maizie hirono
saying something incredibly dumb and as
we will see i mean this is stalinist
it really is stalin-esque stuff the
dictionary webster's dictionary
went in and revised their definition of
the term
sexual preference to reflect this
newfound
umbrage taken by democrats so within 30
seconds of democrats redefining
the term sexual preference to be
offensive webster's dictionary redefined
its own definition
okay this is stalin disappearing people
from the photos here's maisie hirono
originally laying out this idiocy
not once but twice you use the term
sexual preference to describe those in
the lgbtq
community and let me make clear sexual
preference is an offensive and outdated
term
it is used by anti-lgbtq activists
to suggest that sexual orientation is a
choice
it is not sexual orientation is a key
part
of a person's identity that sexual
orientation
is both a normal expression of human
sexuality and
immutable okay and again coney barrett's
looking at her like what are you talking
about i haven't suggested anything to
the contrary there what are you what
what in the world so webster's
dictionary i mean this is how fast these
things this is when we say
that the institutions are stacked
against not only conservatives but
against reason
this is this is why our cultural
institutions are stacked and they are
stacked on behalf of the left
they are willing to redefine dictionary
terms in order to meet
with democratic and woke fascisty
approval
okay literally yesterday yesterday they
went in and redefined webster's
dictionary
redefined the definition of preference
okay so
the fifth definition of preference in
webster's dictionary
up until yesterday was orientation as in
sexual preference
okay they went in they redefined the
term yesterday
as soon as this narrative started to
take root to say offensive
see usage below orientation sexual
preference
it's offensive okay they they literally
changed the dictionary definition of a
term
in order to meet with the approval of
democrats it's incredible
and that it really is impressive stuff
it's impressive stuff that the
democratic
machine the media democratic complex
is so well oiled that within 30 seconds
of a
bull bleep nonsensical rhetorical move
to redefine
a long-held american term they'll just
do it no problem
this is gaslighting it's deconstruction
it's it's deconstructionism
at its height this is jacques derrida
driving everybody up a wall
in the name of leftist politics if we
don't have a common language we can't
have
a common conversation and maybe that's
the goal no common conversation we'll
just we'll just shift the
literal definition of human terminology
in order to meet
with particular political preferences
preferences by the way
is meant not offensively there okay so
then the democrats tried to come up with
finally some sort of semblance of a
narrative that they could pick up from
all of this
uh they they tried to say that kamal
harris did a good job with amy coney
baird she did not she did a terrible job
she spent the first 20 minutes of her 30
minutes basically
giving a campaign speech from her
basement it was not particularly
inspiring here was kamala harris
talking directly she was supposed to
question acb instead she's like
i'm going to use this time to talk
directly to the american people oh god
please
please don't if ever somebody comes up
to you and they say i want to talk
directly to you
turn around and run turn around and run
if you
i don't care who you are if this sort of
stuff doesn't bug you then you haven't
been watching politics long enough
before i begin i i wanted to take a
moment to talk directly with the
american people
about where we are and how we got here
so we are in the middle of a deadly
pandemic
that has hit our country harder than any
other country
in the world more than 215
000 of our fellow americans have died
and millions more
including the president republican
members of this
committee and more than 100 frontline
workers here at the capitol complex
have been infected okay what does that
have to do with it coney barrett
the answer is nothing of course this is
just harris posturing and grandstanding
so the democrats tried to say there was
one moment where she got amy coney
barrett except she didn't
she was inexact in her language and
barrett picked her apart here was heroes
harris
asking if it's important for the supreme
court to be impartial
why don't you recuse yourself in acb
saying like look you guys set up the
ginsburg rule you can't do this
do you think it is important for the
american people to believe that supreme
court justices
are independent and fair and impartial
and that
is a yes or no answer please yes senator
harris
a number of my colleagues have asked you
today whether you would recuse yourself
from cases on the affordable care act
you did not directly answer their
questions and instead you described a
process
i can't have you elicit a commitment
from me about how i would make that
decision in advance
that would be wrong okay and that was
the big moment for kamal harris it was
not a big moment
you can tell how badly this went for
democrats because msc msnbc absolutely
melted down we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that you don't want to be
spending any time at the auto body store
you wouldn't want to in the middle of a
covered pandemic but you especially
would not want to
like ever and the reason is because why
would you stand in line
to get up to the front request a part
get a generic part that doesn't work
right or
have them order it online then it takes
a week for it to arrive and your car
still doesn't work instead
why not just go online and do it
yourself go to rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do why would you
spend up to twice as much
for the same priors like say you happen
to need a delphi fg1456 fuel pump
assembly for a 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey
that'll cost you 354 bucks at a big
chain store but you can get it rock auto
for 217
bucks rockauto.com it's a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years
head on over to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers again
those prices reliably low the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
usbox so they know
that we sent you again that is
rockauto.com shapiro and that hell did
you hear about usbox so they know
that we sent you okay in just a second
we'll get to msnbc melting down and then
nancy pelosi
melting down so nancy pelosi it's
amazing nancy pelosi
is trump she's just female and democrat
right as much as the the press love to
talk about how trump hates the media
and how he's thin-skinned and all this
kind of like nancy pelosi makes trump
look like a look like an island of calm
in a river of crazy i mean that's how
bad nancy pelosi is we'll get to nancy
pelosi in just one second first
if you haven't heard already daley
wired's old glory daily wire baseball
bat is back
this is our limited edition handcrafted
custom painted baseball bat emblazoned
with that magical daily wire logo which
means that it is super powerful
since we relaunched on monday they're
almost all sold out today is the last
day they will be available you can still
get yours if you hurry text the keyword
baseball to 83 400 to purchase your bat
today
and if you haven't already head on over
to dailywire.com subscribe become a
member today
members get our articles hand-free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show exclusive readers past
content
available only to daily wire members if
you're considering an all-access
membership
you get to join us on all access live
every night for online and live stream
discussions you also get not one but two
leftist tiers tumblr with your
membership
as well as early sometimes exclusive
access to new
daily wire products so go check us out
over at dailywire.com right now and get
your all
access membership you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so the way you can tell that amy coney
barrett did really well last night
is because all of the media talking
heads were super super angry at her so
ellie mistel who's
lost it uh is now comparing abs acb to
the proud boys on msnbc
this is what passes for intelligent
commentary over on on msnbc
the land of of crazy and they he here
was eliminal just losing it
it's almost like donald trump is telling
her stand back and stand by
right again we have to understand
what this woman is being set to do trump
has already told us
he wants the supreme court to look at
the ballots
it would be the easiest thing in the
world for her to say you know what i'm
not going to do that
the fact that she won't do it tells you
all you need to know about her character
and all you need to know about what she
intends to do if she is confirmed
before the election um she literally
said i can't judge a case until it comes
up before me he's like she's gonna stuff
the ballot box she is like the proud
boys
okay i'm sorry you're a crazy person joy
reid another crazy person on that same
show
she said amy coney barrett doesn't know
the law yes i'm sure that legal expert
joy reid will inform us of the law
here's joy reid informing us of the law
this lady is a let's just remind her
she's a sitting judge right now so she
theoretically knows the law amy
klobuchar who i think also was a very
effective question or today asked her a
pretty simple straightforward question
is voter intimidation illegal
okay uh she she knows the law i'm i'm
fairly certain that she knows the law as
it as it turns out
okay well the the true meltdown of the
day was not over on msnbc it was over on
cnn
so nancy pelosi has been holding up this
stimulus package republicans have
proposed 1.8 trillion dollars in new
spending
to stimulate people who have been hurt
by the lockdown
because again when the government forces
you not to do your business
well then the government has taken
something from you and they ought to
compensate you this is the fifth
amendment the takings clause
even democrats have been slamming nancy
pelosi for her unwillingness
to take any sort of deal andrew yang
over the weekend
tweeted at her and he told pelosi to
take the deal or risk political fallout
he said put politics aside
people are hurting former obama
administration official dan pfeiffer
agreed
telling pelosi to ignore potential risk
and just ink the deal said democrats
should aggressively pursue a coveted
relief deal
with trump as according to emily zenati
over at daily wire
he said it's the right thing to do but
the politics can also work in our favor
even representative rocanna who's very
far to the left like
bernie sanders leftist suggested that a
stimulus package would be
a good idea okay so she was asked about
this by wolf blitzer on cnn
how unused to criticism is nancy pelosi
when she has asked a simple question by
wolf blitzer she loses her damned mind
she starts to look like the the bad guys
at the end of raiders of the lost ark
where their faces melt off i mean she
just
lost it she called she called him a
republican apologist
i mean this was a crazy off the rails
interview and if she weren't the
democrat everybody would be
this is the brilliant strategist we have
all been told is the is the mistress of
our imagination
here was nancy pelosi melting down on
wolf blitzer of all people
excuse me for interrupting madam speaker
but they really need the money right now
uh and even members of i haven't said
that but but even members of your own
caucus
even members of your own caucus madam
speaker uh
want to accept this deal 1.8 trillion
dollars so what do you say to ro khanna
what i say to you is i don't know why
you're always an apologist
and many of your colleagues apologize
for the republican position
rokana that's nice that isn't what we're
going to do
okay wolf blitzer is there an apologist
for the republicans
really wolff blitzer and cnn these are
the
you know how wildly leftist and in your
bubble you have to believe you have to
be to believe that wolf
blitzer is an apologist for the
republicans it got worse by the way
nancy pelosi just
like if trump had done this to any
member of the media be this is a threat
to the free press
how dare anybody treat a member of our
beloved journalistic establishment like
this
this is just terrible the president only
wants his name on a check to go out
before election day
and for the market to go up is that what
this is all about
not allow the president to take credit
if there's a deal that will help
millions of americans
right now he's not that important but
let me say this with all due respect
with all due respect and you know we've
known each other a long time
you really don't know what you're
talking about oh that that was that was
a lot of due respect there i felt that
respect did you feel all the respect
there
with all due respect with all due
respect you're an ass
she's lost her mind oh my goodness my
goodness this is i got
about this is 14 minutes long is 14
minutes of pure pain
in the octagon she got even more
unhinged here she was
do you have any idea of how that's
precisely why they're
short their concerns that's why it's so
so important right now yesterday i spoke
to andrew yang
who says the same thing it's not
everything you want you know
there's a lot there honest to god
you really i ca i can't get over it i
didn't come over here to have
so you're the apologist for the obama
and excuse me
god forbid
uh unbelievable okay and then it
concluded with her saying to wolf
blitzer
i feed poor people what from your twenty
thousand dollar sub zero fridge with
your thirteen dollar
pints of joe of custom-made gelato nancy
that's how you're feeding the poor
here's nancy pelosi talking about i
feed the poor people let them eat cake
literally we're talking about
how you're not feeding the poor people
that's literally the topic of
conversation is why won't you just sign
a 1.8 trillion dollar deal to give
people money
in the middle of the greatest lockdown
in modern american history
and she's like i feed poor people i feed
poor people
nothing here is nancy pelosi concluding
this brilliant interview with wolf bled
to remember this is the most brilliant
strategist of our time we've been told
no you know them i'm just saying i
represent them and we know them
as we say we know them we represent them
don't let the perfect be the enemy of
the good as they say
nowhere near madame speaker always the
case
but we're not even close to the good all
right let's see what happens because
every day
is critically critically important
thanks so much for joining us
sensitivity to our constituents needs i
am sensitive to them because i see them
on the street begging for food
begging for money natal speaker thank
you we feed them
we feed them well no you don't i feed
them and here's a
here's a 13 a 13 pint of ice cream yeah
poor person
that's incredible stuff how do you know
somebody's been in the bubble too long
that's how you know somebody's been in
the bubble too long when wolf blitzer
is owning you in an exchange you've been
in the bubble a little little bit too
long
wild stuff but that media bubble is
extraordinary my media bubble is
incredible so how bad is the media
bubble here is how bad the media bubble
is
so the 16-19 project is garbage i've
talked to you about how the 6019 project
is garbage
and 1619 project posits that the
american experiment is rooted in slavery
that america is a deeply racist horrible
no-good very bad place
and that every problem in america is
traceable to slavery and every good in
america is traceable to slavery
historians pulitzer prize-winning
historians have debunked the
1619 project it is a bad piece
of faux journalism it was crap from the
beginning it is crap now
so brett stevens over the weekend wrote
a column about how it was crap and how
they had
retconned the 1619 project again there's
so much gaslighting and stalinesque
retconning of history here it's it's
amazing in the original 1619 project
literally had a graphic of the of the
term 1776 crossed out and over it
superimposed
1619. it literally said what would it
mean to consider 1619 the true founding
of america rather than 1776.
when this came up nicole hannah jones
ran from it was metaphorical
we never meant that 1776 didn't matter
you literally wrote in your original
essay the revolutionary war
was fought at least in part to preserve
slavery which is a lie it is not true
okay so it was a it was a bad piece of
journalism
the new york times has defended its bad
piece of journalism
but the fact that they even ran a piece
by brett stevens criticizing the 1619
project and their rewriting of their own
history
causing nicole hannah jones to
absolutely melt down remember nicole
hannah jones is one of the prized
nicole hannah jones she gets to claim
that she's a victim of discrimination in
america while writing absolute horse
for the most prestigious paper in
america
and then winning a pulitzer prize for
writing stuff that is blatantly untrue
wouldn't even do basic fact checking on
her own piece she would appeal at
surprise for that
and then she claims that she's the
victim of racism against black women by
exactly the people who pay her
give her a job and defend her bull crap
it's amazing it's an amazing
amazing thing so how bad
a person is nicole hannah jones so brett
stevens puts out this column
right and then the new york times
leadership put out a bunch of statements
about how they loved the 1619 project
right
they wanted to make her happy dean
baquette put out a a notice to the
entire newsroom
about the 1619 project in the wake of
brett stephen's column quote
1619 is one of the most important pieces
of journalism the times has produced
under my tenure as executive editor it
changed the way the country talked about
race and our history it has given
millions of americans a new framework
and a critical new date 1619
for understanding the nation's past okay
first of all
nicole hannah jones has said it wasn't
journalism right she said that
she actually said that it was a piece of
of historic rethinking
it wasn't really journalism so much so
it has also generated a lot of debate
this is a dean maquette that's no
surprise work that boldly challenges
prevailing views usually
usually does a column this weekend in
our opinion section took issue with the
1619 project
as the editor who runs the newsroom i do
not oversee opinion or the views of its
columnist i do welcome opinion's role in
hosting a wide range of views
including those that challenge our work
this column however raised questions
about the journalistic ethics and
standards of 1619 and the work of nicole
hannah jones who inspired and drove the
project
that criticism i firmly reject okay so
sure we can have like an open-ended
debate on the 1619 project and whether
nicole hannah jones is full of crap
but we can't do that sorry guys actually
as it turns out we don't want to do that
because an open debate
would uh would mean that that you offend
nicole hannah jones and we are never
allowed to offend nicolas jones
never ever offend nicole hanchoon she
is one of the holy she's one of the
sainted she can speak whatever nonsense
comes into her mind
she can pretend that she is speaking
truth about american history while
overtly pushing lies
after being told that they are lies and
we will defend her this is the new york
times journalistic standard
she says the project fell fully within
our standards as a news organization yes
this i believe i believe that the new
york times's
news organization standards do include
promoting overtly false material by the
way when you ever see the fact checkers
on facebook or on twitter fact checking
right wing sites
and claiming that they're doing things
out of context when they ever gonna fact
check the 6019 project at any point of
course not
the new york times is spending millions
of dollars to promote the 6019 project
on on facebook they spent literally i
believe three million dollars on like
three ads for the 1619 project on
facebook
according to uh outside estimates but
dean baquette says in fact 1619
especially the work of nicole
fill me with pride our readers i believe
our country have benefited immensely
from the principled rigorous
groundbreaking journalism of nicole and
the full team of writers and editors who
brought us this
transformative work like there's only
one problem
it's a it's garbage it's just it's
garbage but the new york times defended
it
that was not enough guys do you
understand that's not enough for nicole
hannah jones
they wrote dean baquette put out a full
statement talking about how
much he wished to lend his body to the
mercies of nicole hannah jones
how much he wished to lend his
institutional
in his institutional integrity to the
predations of nicole hannah jones
how he wished that he could lie down on
puddles so nicole hannah jones could
walk over him and nicole hannah jones
was not having any of it
she is the victim
oh yes according to the washington post
hannah jones was livid
she led opinions editor kathleen
kingsbury and brett stevens know it in
emails ahead of publication
on the day the national association of
scholars called for the revocation of
her pulitzer
she tweeted that efforts to discredit
her work quote put me in a long
tradition of
black women who failed to know their
places she changed her twitter bio to
slanderous and nasty minded mulatras a
tribute to trailblazing journalist ida b
wells whom the time slurred with those
same words in 1894. okay number one this
in 1894
two she ain't i to be wells iv wells was
reporting true things nicole hannah
jones overtly
is overtly reporting false things ida
wells was slandered for her race nicole
hannah jones is being granted extra
credit because of hers
if nicole hannah jones were not of
diverse ancestry if nicole hannah jones
was just a white lady working for the
new york times writing
stuff that turned out to be overtly
false she would be on suspension right
now
especially if she'd been warned prior
that the stuff that she was writing was
not true
hannah jones uh now acknowledges that
she should have been more careful with
how she wrote certain passages but
my goodness everything everything for
for nico it must be wonderful to be able
to simply reply to all of your mistakes
and people pointing them out by claiming
that it is an act of racism to point all
of that out
this is the wonderful thing about our
woke culture is that
there are no limits to the woke culture
a couple more examples on the wolf
culture this one is is fully insane
so there is a group called wnet group
it's the parent company of new york's
public television stations
they've now called for the resignation
of the long time chief executive neil
shapiro they say he has not done enough
to improve
working condition for employees
especially those of color
so what exactly did he do well the big
problem is that neil shapiro
is not a person of color he is a former
president of nbc news he has led w net
since 2007.
he uh he apparently he apparently said
that much of what has been written is
inaccurate misleading or out of context
w net has a workforce of 380 people 70
of whom identify as white which by the
way is about the same constituency as
the country the country is
uh in the mid-60s in terms of percentage
white
apparently people are very angry at
shapiro why why are they angry at
shapiro not really because of what he
has done
with his personnel but because of this
you ready for this this is how crazy
people are this is how crazy
our woke race fascisti are on june 1st
six days after george floyd's death
shapiro released a statement on wnet.org
quote racism is a cancer in the soul of
this nation
this has been an agonizing and painful
week our hearts go out to so many
especially so for our african-american
colleagues
at the same time it is a reminder of
what drew many of us to public media to
help build a more informed country with
equal justice for everyone based on
understanding and mutual respect that
sounds like a pretty woke statement
right
right racism is a cancer in the soul of
the nation and we have to show that
equal justice is still a reality for
black americans right he's buying into
the systemic american racism narrative
of course
this was bad the statement it was not
good enough so let's see
let's play let's play racial jeopardy
can you woke jeopardy here we go
can you name for 400 what in that
statement is the problem
time's up okay so what is the problem in
the statement
according to the inclusion and diversity
council they objected to shapiro
likening racism to cancer quote it is
our view that this represents your
profound misunderstanding of our
nation's history and its current reality
racism is not an anomaly separate from
us rather it is woven into the fabric of
this country
and in fact our own institution
amazing amazing amazing
okay also they did something else that's
bad right so first of all you're not
allowed to say racism
is a cancer it's an inherent part of you
it's not something that you can remove
from it can never be removed it is
inextricably intertwined with your
identity racism
which means of course it's never
healable because it's part of who you
are all you can do is shut up
all you can do is shut up and listen my
goodness
okay another point of contention between
the inclusion and diversity council
which again these these institutions
when they talk about inclusion and
diversity it doesn't sound like they're
very inclusive
like of anything and these are all
orwellian terms the inclusion and
diversity council got mad
because there was a 30 sec a 36 second
video the company posted
on its social media accounts on june 3rd
set to a plaintiff pianos according to
the new york times the video presented
images of harmony between new york city
police officers and citizens
in one photo a black man in a hoodie has
seen fist bumping a white police officer
in riot gear in another a white police
officer marches in a protest
next to a black woman wearing a black
lives matter t-shirt
the montage also showed a black woman
embracing a police officer the inclusion
and diversity council
said the video displayed quote bias in
favor of the police and w net removed it
removed it by the way how crazy is this
council
so the company appointed a woman in
eugenia harvey an executive producer who
had joined wnet in 2018
to a new position chief diversity equity
and inclusion officer
the diversity council criticized
harvey's promotion
why well harvey is black but they hadn't
been consulted before the move
they say being a black woman is not
enough of a qualification to head
diversity at a company
like ours this is a big deal it was not
treated with proper respect
we feared that neil shapiro was creating
a shield for himself using a black woman
as the shield
okay i'm sorry if you choose to if you
choose to couch out to this sort of
stuff you get you deserve
every single thing that you get and
frankly i am experiencing nothing but
troyd and fred for people who came to
this stuff and then are getting it good
and hard
they deserve it speaking of people who
are getting it good and hard
meredith r who is a in the nbc top
unscripted executive
she is now out she and nbc's former
entertainment president have been
accused of fostering a toxic workplace
the inquiry sprang from a hollywood
reporter report on allegations of
homophobic misogynistic
and racist behavior especially within
the network's reality division
sources say the investigator interviewed
more than 60 current and former network
employees
and found that our's behavior was not in
line with the standards the company
expects especially from its senior
leaders hilariously enough
who is meredith r well according to
deadline hollywood go all the way back
to may 2019
in nbc's ongoing advocacy for
representation in key production roles
they've launched the network's first
below the line initiatives the two newly
created pipeline programs
focus on diversifying representation
among production coordinators and
production assistants
the new annual initiatives are
spearheaded by nbc's scripted
programming co-presidents lisa katz and
tracy pacosta
alternative and reality group president
meredith r
oh so they made her queen of diversity
and uh and then it turns out she created
a toxic work culture
in uh in thwarting diversity so
everything's going great
in diversity land yep the woke come for
all
you can feed the alligator hoping it
will eat you last but you will still be
eaten and probably
not last alright we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content
we'll get to mitt romney's statement
about donald trump we'll get to donald
trump
tweeting out about joe biden he tweeted
oddly enough that
that and uh immorally enough that joe
biden was a resident of an old age home
which um is on a meme level hilarious
and on a political level
it's a bold strategy when you need to
win people above 65 to call your
opponents a member of an old age home
but you know
i'm not the president we'll get to that
a little bit later and a new proposal
to reach herd immunity that has the left
and the media
being driven up a wall we'll talk to a
high-ranking epidemiologist about it
this afternoon so make sure that you
stick around for that otherwise we'll
see you here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nico geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen